[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen Fußball gibt es von Sven Voß
sehr gerne auch von mir einen schönen
guten Abend und in Berlin gab es eine
Premiere
der König der Bundestag und eine
besondere Rede Charles der dritte sieht
berät nun deutsche in einer gemeinsamen
Führungsrolle
es tut sich was bei den Preisen die
Inflationsrate sinkt auf 7,4%
Lebensmittel bleiben aber sehr teuer
und erstmals seit Jahren nimmt die
Kriminalität wieder zu auffällig ist das
immer mehr Jugendliche zu Tätern werden
[Musik]
er ist der erste König der im Bundestag
eine Rede gehalten hat der britische
König Charles der dritte teils auf
Deutsch humorvoll und begleitet von viel
Applaus Sprache zu den Abgeordneten die
deutsche Militärhilfe für die Ukraine
ernannte Charles
es ist ganz still als Charles der dritte
in den Plenarsaal kommt hat es so auch
noch nicht gegeben dass ein Monarch im
Parlament spricht nicht angemessen sagt
die Linke ansonsten er Wohlwollen und
hochrangige Besetzung Charles der dritte
spricht meist Deutsch er ist so
politisch wie es ihm möglich ist und
lobt den deutschen Einsatz für die
Ukraine betont die gemeinsame
Führungsrolle wir sind erschüttet von
der fruchtbaren Zerstörung
aber wir können Mut schöpfen aus unserer
Einigkeit
so Verteidigung der Ukraine
des Friedens und der Freiheit seine Rede
hat das britische Außenministerium
vorgegeben sie trägt auch seine
Handschrift ein neuer Ton fast so als
hätte es den brexit nie gegeben der
König bemüht wohl nicht zufällig die
Geschichte verweist auf den freien
Handel im Mittelalter
wo waren flossen flossen auch Ideen und
die Menschen ließen sich voneinander
inspirieren
nicht nur die Geschichte verbinde auch
die Zukunft der Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel aber auch die Kultur und der
Humor
natürlich gibt es auch Rivalität ich
denke da besonders an die Begegnungen
zwischen unseren Fußballmannschaft Witz
Ernsthaftigkeit Vergangenheit und
Zukunft Charles der dritte spannt einen
weiten Bogen am Ende viel Applaus von
allen Parteien
Türkei welche Bedeutung hat diese Rede
also sie ist in jedem Fall ein wichtiges
Signal und das gleiche in mehrfacher
Hinsicht sie betont und stärkt die
Bedeutung der deutsch-britischen
Beziehung geht aber auch darüber hinaus
in gewisser Weise steht Deutschland da
stellvertretend für Europa denn
wirtschaftlich spürt Großbritannien ja
längst die negativen Folgen des brexit
der Handel mit der EU geht zurück und
politisch zeigt sich in den Zeiten eines
russischen angriffskriegs und einer
Verschiebung der internationalen Ordnung
ja wie wichtig eine europäische
Zusammenarbeit ist King Charles hat auch
deshalb heute die Zusammenarbeit bei der
Unterstützung der Ukraine besonders
betont es ist ja seine erste Reise als
König und vor der Krönung auch die
einzige also auch damit hat Charles ein
starkes Signal gesetzt wir Briten wollen
wieder bessere Beziehungen mit euch und
wissendes hinter seiner Reise die
britische Regierung steht verleiht das
einer überwiegend diplomatischen rede
dann doch größere politische Bedeutung
danke schön für diese Einschätzung
der Königs im Bundestag
ja und ansonsten verbrachten König
Charles und seine Frau Camilla einen
Großteil ihres Tages draußen bei den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern zeigten sich
volksnah morgen geht es dann weiter von
Berlin nach Hamburg zusammen mit
Bundespräsident Steinmeier Roman Lesko
war über Tag 2 des Staatsbesuches
höflich bedankt sich Camilla erste
Geschenke von Passanten auf dem
bio-wochen-markt heute Vormittag in
Berlin Schöneberg auch am zweiten Tag
sucht das Königspaar den direkten
Kontakt diesmal mit Kunden und Händlern
Charles Interesse an nachhaltiger
Landwirtschaft beeindruckt
und sie waren sehr höflich und sehr
verbindlich er hätte ja auch ganz
wunderbar und bequem ins KaDeWe gehen
können hätte sich dahin setzen können
nein es auf einen Wochenmarkt gegangen
der Terminkalender dicht gedrängt heute
am frühen Nachmittag besucht es
ehemaligen Flughafen Tegel mittlerweile
gleichermaßen Verteilzentrum und
provisorische Unterkunft für ukrainische
geflüchtete schon in seiner
bundestagsrede gegen Charles auf den
Krieg ein hier für den Gespräche mit
Betroffenen
dann geht es nach Brandenburg weiter
nahe Finowfurt beobachtet der König eine
Übung des deutsch-britischen
pionier-brückenbataillons
der letzte Termin das Ökodorf Brodowin
biologische Käseproduktion unter den
Augen eines britischen royales das
offizielle Programm endet mit einem
kräftigen Gewitterguss morgen geht es
für Charles und Camilla weiter nach
Hamburg
die Europäische Union will ihr
Verhältnis zu China neu ausrichten da
das Land zunehmend härter auftrete um
seine Interessen in der Welt
durchzusetzen so
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
heute in einer Grundsatzrede das Ziel
von China unabhängiger werden gerade
auch wirtschaftlich über die schwierigen
Beziehungen berichtet Florian neuer
wie blickt Europa auf China es ist ein
neuer Ton den Ursula von der Leyen heute
anstimmt so deutlich wie die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin hat noch kaum
jemand in politischer Verantwortung
Chinas Macht streben beschrieben
Ziel der Kommunistischen Partei Chinas
ist ein systemischer Wandel zu einer
internationalen Ordnung in deren
Mittelpunkt china steht
im Mittelpunkt und an der Seite
Russlands ohne jegliche Kritik am
russischen Krieg wie zuletzt beim Besuch
von Staatspräsident key in Moskau Europa
müssen so von der Leyen seine
China-Politik daher neu ausrichten ein
Beispiel das Abkommen zum
Investitionsschutz auf das sich Europa
und China noch 2020 im Grundsatz
verständigt hatten von der Leyen will
das Abkommen neu bewerten übersetzt es
hat wohl keine Zukunft mehr Europa will
unabhängiger werden und bleibt doch
angewiesen auf China etwa bei Rohstoffen
für Elektroautos 97% des Lithiums in der
EU kommen aktuell aus China es gäbe
Alternativen doch auf Chinas Lieferung
zu verzichten ist kurzfristig nicht
realistisch
ich glaube es ist wieder umsetzbar noch
im Interesse Europas sich von China
abzukoppeln am Dienstag reißt sie selbst
nach Peking zusammen mit Frankreichs
Präsident macron
in Brüssel macht man sich wenig
Illusionen Europas Einfluss auf die
chinesische Staatsführung ist ziemlich
begrenzt Europas Abhängigkeit der Gegend
ist wohl ungleich höher als die von
Russland noch vor dem Krieg noch ist es
nicht zu spät daraus Lehren zu ziehen
das ist von der Lions wichtigste
Botschaft heute
Stichwort erneuerbare Energien da
schreibt sich Europa weitaus
ehrgeizigere Ziele als bisher auf die
Fahne das Europa-Parlament und die
EU-Mitgliedstaaten haben sich darauf
geeinigt dass der Anteil von wind solar
und Wasserkraft am Energieverbrauch im
Jahr 2030 bei
42,5 Prozent liegen soll bisher hieß das
Ziel 32 Prozent zuletzt machten
erneuerbare Quellen 22% der eu-energie
aus
relativ milde Temperaturen und
Einsparungen machen es möglich die
gasspeichern Deutschland kommen relativ
gut gefüllt aus dem Winter aktuell liegt
der Stand bei gut
64%. der Präsident der Netzagentur
müller sprach von einem großen Erfolg
das werde helfen die Speicher auch für
den nächsten Winter ohne russisches Gas
zu befüllen
der ukrainekrieg und die Energiekrise
wirken sich seit einem Jahr massiv auf
die Preise bei uns aus nun ist die
Inflationsrate zum ersten Mal wieder
deutlich gesunken für den März geht das
Statistische Bundesamt vorläufig von 7,4
Prozent aus im letzten halben Jahr waren
es meist deutlich über 8 Prozent Grund
sind vor allem sinkende Sprit und
Heizölpreise
für Entwarnung ist es allerdings noch zu
früh weil die Halle an der Börse woran
liegt das zu früh weil sich die
Energiepreise nicht wirklich erholt
haben die Preise von heute die werden
nämlich verglichen mit den Preisen von
vor einem Jahr und da waren sie schon
hoch wegen des Ukraine Krieges somit
kann man schon sagen sind die
Energiepreise nach wie vor auf hohem
Niveau die Zahlen zeigen aber auch dass
sich die Inflation nicht mehr nur auf
Energie und Lebensmittel beschränkt sie
ist in der Breite der Wirtschaft
angekommen vieles ist also teurer
geworden und Preistreibern Nummer eins
waren im März mit Abstand Lebensmittel
plus 22% gegenüber dem Vorjahr Energie
wurde in Anführungsstrichen kaum noch
teurer um drei einhalb Prozent also
tatsächlich keine Entwarnung zumal man
auch abwarten muss wie sich die höheren
Löhne auf die Preise auswirken vor allem
bei Dienstleistungen wo ja die
Personalkosten stark ins Gewicht fallen
unterm Strich kann man sagen die
Inflation hat den Höhepunkt vermutlich
überschritten durch greifen besser
dürfte es aber frühestens kommendes Jahr
werden danke schön Valeria
nach Jahren des Rückgangs hat die
Kriminalität in Deutschland wieder
zugenommen
im vergangenen Jahr registrierten die
Polizeibehörden 5,6 Millionen Straftaten
11,5% mehr als im Vorjahr das hat doch
was mit dem Wegfall der corona-maßnahmen
zu tun aber auch im Vergleich zum vor
coronajahr 2019 gab es im
zurückliegenden Jahr noch 3,5% mehr
Delikte Klaus Brodbeck
selten ist Kriminalität so augenfällig
wie die Krawalle in der Silvesternacht
doch sie nimmt zu in vielen Bereichen
das ist ein deutlicher Anstieg wir sehen
in welchen Bereichen wir handeln müssen
und trotzdem gilt weiterhin wir sind ein
starker Rechtsstaat und ein sicheres
Land im Vergleich zu vor Corona stieg
die Zahl der Delikte bei
Wirtschaftskriminalität um 80 gegen Asyl
und Aufenthaltsrecht um 36 und die von
Vergewaltigungen und sexuellen
Übergriffen um 26 Prozent hier wohl auch
durch ein deutlich verändertes
Anzeigeverhalten
92,4 Prozent der Opfer von Straftaten
gegen die sexuelle Selbstbestimmung sind
weiblich
92,4%. auch die sprunghaft angestiegene
Zahl von geflüchteten vor allem durch
den Krieg in der Ukraine wirkt sich auf
die deutsche Kriminalstatistik aus die
Nettozuwanderung nach Deutschland
Belag nach etwa 330.000 Personen im Jahr
2021 mit über 1,4 Millionen Personen im
letzten Jahr auf einem historischen
Höchstwert natürlich steigt dann auch
Kriminalität die Zahl deutscher
Jugendlicher Tatverdächtiger stieg
ebenfalls deutlich womöglich eine Folge
vermehrten Stresses durch Corona sie
könnte auch schnell wieder sinken
und die gestiegene Kriminalität bei
Jugendlichen ist auch Thema bei heute
live gleich nach unserer Sendung um
19.30 auf unseren Social Media Kanälen
und in der ZDF heute App
schon mehrfach hat der Kreml westlichen
Reporterinnen und Reportern vorgeworfen
unter dem Deckmantel des Journalismus zu
spionieren jetzt hat ein Gericht in
Moskau Haftbefehl gegen einen
Mitarbeiter der US-Zeitung Wall Street
Journal erlassen die Regierung von
Washington verurteilt das auf schärfste
Evan gözkovic war zuvor in Jekaterinburg
festgenommen worden er habe versucht
geheime Informationen über einen
Militärkomplex zu erhalten sein Anwalt
wie ist die Vorwürfe zurück
bis zu 20 Jahre Haft
seit Jahren bedrohen russische Hacker
Deutschland die Vorwürfe sie knacken die
IT-Systeme des Bundestages wollen Wahlen
beeinflussen legen stattverwaltungen
lahm zu beweisen dass hinter vielen
dieser Angriffe tatsächlich staatliche
Stellen in Moskau stecken ist oft nur
schwer möglich ein internationales Team
von Reporterinnen und Reportern an dem
ZDF frontal beteiligt war bekam aber nun
erstmals einen Einblick in die
cyberkriegspläne Russlands und seiner
Geheimdienste Christian Rode berichtet
das Bürogebäude im Nordosten von Moskau
wirkt unscheinbar doch hinter diesen
Fenstern werden im Geheimen Programme
für den russischen Cyberkrieg entwickelt
ein Whistleblower hat Journalisten
tausende interne Dokumente einer
IT-Firma überlassen ihr Name NTC Vulkan
die programmiert zum Beispiel Software
mit folgenden Zielen
lahmlegen von Kontrollsystemen von
Eisenbahn luft-
Papiere aus Moskau ein internationales
journalisten-team darunter ZDF und
Spiegel mit den vulkanfalls liegen
erstmals umfassende Belege vor wie der
Kreml weltweit Cyberangriffe organisiert
an diesem Beispiel wird deutlich dass es
eine reale Gefahr aus dem cyberraum gibt
für die kritische Infrastruktur in
Deutschland in den internen Dokumenten
steht auch wie Desinformation verbreitet
werden soll zum Beispiel in russisch
besetzten Gebieten Anfragen von Usern
werden auf erwünschte
Internet-Ressourcen in vorgesehenen
Territorien umgeleitet heißt es da
westliche Nachrichtendienste bestätigen
die Echtheit der vulkanpfeils erst
Firmen wie Vulkan würden russische
Geheimdienste zu Cyberattacken auf den
Westen bewegen
er hat für Vulkan gearbeitet und die
Firma mittlerweile verlassen nicht ohne
Grund
Russland ist ein Polizeistaat ich will
helfen dass Regime zu schwächen die
Leute sollen wissen dass es Firmen gibt
wie Vulkan die diese Art von Software
entwickeln auf detaillierte Fragen zu
Putin Cyberkrieg haben weder die
russische Regierung noch die Firma
Vulkan geantwortet
die ganze Dokumentation des Teams von
ZDF frontal gibt es in der Mediathek und
weitere Hintergründe zu den russischen
cyberkriegsplänen finden Sie in unserer
ZDF heute App
massive Warnstreiks Verhandlungen bis
tief in die Nacht und am Ende keine
Einigung die Tarifverhandlungen für rund
2,5 Millionen Beschäftigte im
öffentlichen Dienst sind gescheitert
wenn die Chef Wernicke sprach von nicht
überbrückbaren unterschieden und es
Innenministerin Phaser kündigte eine
Schlichtung an eine Kommission muss nun
bis Mitte April ein Lösungsvorschlag
erarbeiten große Streiks wir am
vergangenen Montag gibt es bis dahin
nicht ab Sonntag gilt Friedenspflicht
eine wichtige Änderung für
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer gibt
es zum Monatswechsel vom 1 April an es
ist nicht mehr möglich sich telefonisch
krankschreiben zu lassen diese
Sonderregelung war zu Beginn der
corona-pandemie eingeführt worden um
Arztpraxen zu entlasten
die Bahn rechnet in diesem Jahr mit
einem neuen fahrgastrekord in ihren
Fernzügen 155 Millionen Passagiere das
dürfte die Bundesregierung freuen die
den Verkehr deutlich mehr auf die
Schiene verlagern möchte
trotzdem hat die Bahn weiter mit
massiven Schwierigkeiten zu kämpfen zum
Beispiel kamen 2022 nur rund 65% der
Fernzüge pünktlich ein neuer Tiefstwert
mehr zur Jahresbilanz hat jetzt hans-
die Bahn fährt wieder in die schwarzen
Zahlen meldet für das letzte Jahr einen
Gewinn vor Steuern vom 1,3 Milliarden
Euro vor unterm Strich allerdings erneut
Verluste ein der Bahnchef im Video
Statement den wirtschaftlichen Erfolg
verdanken wir wesentlich unserer
logistik-tochter DB Schenker die den
höchsten Umsatz und den höchsten
gewinnen in ihre Geschichte gemacht hat
gleichzeitig waren die Züge im letzten
Jahr noch nie so unpünktlich jeder
dritte Fernzug kommt 2022 verspätet ans
Ziel Hauptgrund das verschlissene
Schienennetz und bis zu 1200 Baustellen
pro Tag jeder ein Risiko für neue
Verspätungen in diesem Jahr kommen
allein 11 weitere Großbaustellen hinzu
die wichtigste zwischen Kassel und Fulda
mehr als 5 Monate Vollsperrung ab diesem
Wochenende alle Züge werden umgeleitet
und brauchen bis zu 1 Stunde länger die
Befürchtung die Gefahr besteht das
Fahrgäste dauerhaft abwandern im weil
Sie es leid sind dass sie eben
stundenlang länger unterwegs sind oder
eben vielleicht überhaupt nicht mehr
fahren können weil keine Sitzplätze mehr
vorhanden sind bei den wenigen Zügen die
noch fahren dabei beginnt die große
Generalsanierung erst im nächsten Jahr
Ausbau der 40 wichtigsten
schienenkorridore weil Arbeiten
gebündelt werden sind die Strecken dann
noch länger gesperrt dafür spätestens ab
2030 auf Jahre Bau frei
kommen wir zum Fußball wir haben es ja
gestern noch gehört sie waren sich so so
sicher dass dieses Halbfinale schaffen
würden Sven schade aber die Frauen des
FC Arsenal waren dann doch dieses eine
Tor besser als der FC Bayern der
Vorsprung aus dem Hinspiel hat am Ende
nicht gereicht Bayern scheitert im
Viertelfinale der Champions League
ausschalten tut weh erst recht wenn sie
so klar ist ein überflüssiger
Ballverlust leitet nach 19 Minuten das
1:0 für Arsenal durch Friedemann um ein
das hinspielergebnis ist damit
ausgeglichen
Diener Platz 5 Minuten später keine Mühe
beim 20 die früher Entscheidung gegen
die ersatzgeschwächten bei ich würde
sagen 20 Minuten waren wir nicht so
wirklich auf dem Platz und die waren im
Endeffekt dann auch tödlich für uns zwei
Titel Chancen bleiben noch für das Team
von Alexander Strauß Meisterschaft und
DFB-Pokal
gerade spielt der VfL Wolfsburg ums
Halbfinale Fußballprofi Mario
wuschkowitsch bleibt wegen Dopings bis
November 20-24 gesperrt dies bestätigte
dass dfb-sportgerät der HSV Spieler
wurde positiv auf EPO getestet da das
verbotene Medikament aber im Urin des
Sportlers nachgewiesen wurde gibt es
Zweifel die Hamburger wollen gegen das
Urteil Berufung einlegen
und auch der erste fC Köln kämpft vor
Gericht nämlich gegen die drastische
Transfersperre durch die FIFA der
Vorwurf Köln soll bei der Verpflichtung
eines jugendspielers die Regeln verletzt
haben der 1 fC Köln darf in der nächsten
Sommer und Winterperiode keine Spieler
verpflichten das betrifft auch die
Profi-Abteilung der Verein reagiert
zieht sofort vor den Internationalen
Sportgerichtshof und liegt Berufung
gegen das FIFA Urteil ein es geht um den
17-Jährigen Slowenien jahrgangschnig der
vor einem Jahr ablösefrei nach Köln
gewechselt war der Spieler der U19 hatte
den Vertrag bei seinem Verein einseitig
gekündigt weil Ljubljana mir sozusagen
diesen Spieler gegeben wurden sind nicht
eingehalten hat dazu haben wir auch
entsprechende Beweise und Zeugenaussagen
Köln hat im Kaserne beweisen und
vorgelegt die Chance auf Milderung ist
groß das zeigen Vereine wie Chelsea oder
Manchester City die zunächst ähnliche
sperren auffällig bekamen
das war's vom Sport Jana danke schön
Sven morgen wird es besonders im Süden
stürmisch außerdem gibt es viel Regen
Details auch zum Wochenende Wetter
gleich von Katja Hornbach
Slomka begrüßt sie um 21:45 Uhr zum
heute journal bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend morgen geht der März zu Ende
es ist der nasseste März seit 2001
deutschlandweit vielen 90 Liter pro
Quadratmeter 60% mehr als im
vierjährigen klimatologischen Mittel die
Dürre der letzten Jahre konnte das nicht
ausgleichen jetzt kommt noch mal Regen
dazu mit dem Sturmtief Markus dass ich
hier über dem Atlantik einkringelt und
jetzt gerade die Bretagne erreicht davor
zieht ein weiteres Tief hier ostwärts ab
und das bringt uns heute Nacht noch
einige Schauer und Gewitter die
nordostwärts abziehen in der zweiten
Nachthälfte setzt dann kräftiger Regen
im Südwesten ein das wird noch mal eine
milde Nacht mit Tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen 12 und 5 Grad die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen bei 11
bis 16 Grad und besonders in der
Nordhälfte wird das ein sehr verregneter
Freitag da werden sie die Sonne kaum mal
zu Gesicht bekommen im Süden klappt das
mit der Sonne am Nachmittag etwas besser
da geht's sehr kräftige Regenschauer und
Gewitter und eben diesen starken diesen
stürmischen windböden von 60 bis 90 km
pro Stunde erwarten wir im und auf den
Bergen sogar über 100 Kilometer pro
Stunde der Samstag wird noch sehr
verregnet und dann wird es von Norden
immer kälter guten Abend